So Anchor, I was thinking that there
are so many game apps out there already,
why would I look for
another game to play when there's
already Bejeweled and Fruit Ninja?
>> That's a great question, because even
if a new game is a lot of fun to play,
it won't necessarily be profitable.
And its popularity may fade with time.
Luckily, that's what
this course is about.
We'll talk about three main
topics that'll help your game
keep its players coming back and
help you make money.
What are those topics Suzanne?
>> Well, the first lesson
will be about engagement.
Which is how to design your game so
that people play it often and
stay interested over time.
The second lesson will discuss
the different models for
monetization, like using ads and
in-app purchases.
And our third and last lesson will
be about publishing best practices,
like testing your game and
getting your game noticed.
>> As you go through this course,
keep in mind that the best and
the easiest way to make your game
profitable is to start thinking about
monetization right away.
As you're building your game,
don't leave it as a last step.